[Music]  after we made contact with the engineers  the Prometheus was destroyed all hands  were lost but I escaped with Elizabeth  in one of their ships I was badly  injured on our mission she put me back  together  that never experienced such compassion  certainly not for mr. Weyland or from  any human  Green train  right - right  have to be civil do yes if I kind of  heart  you know we were able to activate their  ship and set course for the whole we  were finally going to meet our Creator  how long impossible to say what is that  all better  so long as there are no worse  sleep tight  I'll wake you when we arrive  and then I was alone again I learned of  their ways and awaited  our arrival  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  look up my wife  [Music]  [Music]